قرر رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان حميدتي
في اجتماع انعقد السبت بمشاركه القوى
المدنيه الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
قرروا المضي قدما في الترتيبات السياسيه
المتفق عليها ياتي هذا بعد تاكيد الجيش
السوداني التزامه الصارم والتام بالاتفاق
الايطالي ومطالبه القوى الرافضه للاتفاق
للجيش بالحياد ازاء السياسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذكاء خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي اتجاه وضع بيان
الجيش ومخرجات اجتماع البرهان وحميدتي
العمليه السياسيه المتعثره في البلاد
وعلى اي نحو جاءت استجابه القوى المدنيه
لتحرك وتصريحات من العسكريين وما خياراتهم
للتعامل معها واخيرا ما هي المسارات
المحتمله للاوضاع الامنيه والسياسيه في
السودان في ضوء هذه التصريحات
[موسيقى]
على واقع انباء تواترت بشده خلال الفتره
الماضيه عن خلافات بين قيادتي الجيش
والدعم السريع اللذين يتزعمهما على
التوالي رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان حميدتي انعقد
يوم السبت في الخرطوم قال بيان لمجلس
السياده انه بحث الاوضاع السياسيه
والامنيه في البلاد بمشاركه من القوى
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي قرر
الاجتماع بحسب البيان تكوين لجنه امنيه
مشتركه من القوات النظاميه واجهزه الدوله
ذات الصله وحركات الكفاح المسلح لمتابعه
الاوضاع الامنيه في البلاد كما اقر المضيه
قدما فيما سماها بيان مجلس السياده
الترتيبات المتفقه عليها بشان العمليه
السياسيه وقالت مصادر في قوى الحريه
والتغيير مجموعه المجلس المركزي للجزيره
هنا اداه من قوى الحريه والتغيير ناقشت في
اجتماعها مع البرهان واحمد الترتيبات
الخاصه بورشه الاصلاح العسكري وذلك ضمن
الورش الخاصه بالعمليه السياسيه وصولا الى
الاتفاق النهائي
المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني العميد نبيل
عبد الله كان اكد قبيل اجتماع البرهان
واحمدتي التزام القوات المسلحه
وقيادتهما بالعمليه السياسيه
وتقيدها الصارم والتام بالاتفاق الايطالي
الموقع في الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي مع قوى
مدنيه سودانيه ابرزها قوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي
تؤكد قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجريات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه فيما تبقى من
المرحله الانتقاليه لحين قيام الانتخابات
بنهايتها ان مزايده البعض بمواقف قواتنا
المسلحه وهي اول من بادر بالخروج من
العمليه السياسيه لن تنطلع على فطنه الشعب
ووعي ثوار وثائرات وشباب بلادنا
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم
عروه الصادقه القيادي في تحالف الحريه
والتغيير مجموعه المجلس المركزي
ومحيي الدين ابراهيم القيادي في الكتله
الديمقراطيه واللواء المتقاعد الرشيد
المعتصم الباحث في الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اهلا بكم جميعا فيما وراء الخبر وابدا معك
استاذ عروه الصادق هذا الحراك الذي شهدناه
خلال اليومين الاخيرين اين يضع الازمه في
السودان التي تتفاعل منذ فتره
اولا حياك الله سيدتي وحي الحاضرين من
المشاهدين والمشاهدات وحياه طواقم الجزيره
على امتداد المعموره اقول وحيا ضيفيك
الكريمين اقول ان هذه الخطوه التي
بداها نبيل العميد اركان حرب نبيل الناطق
الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه ومن بعده
لحيقها البيان المقتضب من مجلس السياده
وضعت العمليه السياسيه في اخر خطواتها
النهائيه ما يعني اننا ازفنا الى الوصول
الى حل نهائي لهذه الازمه باعتبار ان
هنالك تمنع ظلت تمارسه قياده القوات
المسلحه طوال الفترات السابقه وتخلق
جماعات تناور بها كمجموعه تجديد ومن بعدها
مجموعه القاهره ومجموعات كثيره حاولت
تعطيل العمليه السياسيه الان هنالك صوت
عالي داخل منظومه القوات المسلحه بان هذه
العمليه يمكن ان توصل البلاد الى حل سياسي
يخرجها مما دخلت فيه في اكتوبر باعتبار ان
راس الانقلاب المنقسم بين الدعم السريع
وقياده القوات المسلحه نصفه قال بان ما
حدث في 25 اكتوبر انقلاب واجب التصحيح
لذلك نرى ان بيان الجيش واجب الترحيب به
باعتبار انه بيان منضبط وصادر عن القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه ولم يصدر من
مستشاري البرهان او من مكتب البرهان في
مجلس السياده وهذه لها دلالاتها حتى ان
العبارات بالنسبه لنا في الحريه والتغيير
حسبناها بدقه والدقيقه باعتبار انها
عبارات مصرمه منضبطه قاطعه على لبسه فيها
ولا محاوله للمناوره كما كان يحدث في
اللقاءات الشفهيه التي انتظمت مخاطبات
رئيس مجلس السياده وغيره من القيادات
العسكريه اذا هذا ما يراه تحالف الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي ماذا عنكم انتم
في الكتله الديمقراطيه السيد محي الدين
ابراهيم كيف تقيمون هذا الحرك
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا وتحيه للجزيره
لهذه الفرصه اولا ما يدور الان في العمليه
السياسيه هو ليس امر جديد نحن شهدنا هذه
هذه الاحداث في فتره ما قبل 25 اكتوبر في
تلك الفتره كانت هذه المجموعه تحاول ان
تختتف العمليه السياسيه وتحاول ان تسيطر
على البلاد بكل المفاصل الدوله بما فيها
المؤسسه العسكريه نحن وشاهدنا يعني
لهذه
الاهداف يعني فتره احداث 25 اكتوبر خمسين
اكتوبر كانت هي خطوه لتصحيح المسار ولا
تصحيح الثوره السودانيه التي خرج الشعب
السوداني واسقاط الذي اسقط النظام
وبالتالي اسس لفتره جديده يجب ان تكون هذه
الفتره فتره لتاسيس الدوله السودانيه
الاسس جديده وتحقيق كافه التطورات الشعبه
السودانيه نحن الان ما يتم الان في
العمليه السياسيه هي محاوله جديده لهذه
المجموعه بمجموعه المركزي هي مجموعه قليله
جدا تحاول ان يعني تسيطر على العمليه
السياسيه وتحاول ان تنفرد بالعمليه
السياسيه مره اخرى نحن نتابع هذه الاهداف
وهذه هذا الاتفاق سبب في ازمه سياسيه حاده
في البلاد وسبب ايضا في السراء ما بين
المؤسسه العسكريه وقوات الدعم السريه كذلك
انعكس سلبا على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والاوضاع الامنيه في البلاد والاوداء يعني
الاجتماعيه نحن هذا الاتفاق الاطاري هو
اتفاق ولد ميتا ولا يستطيع ان يجمع كافه
القوى السياسيه التي لديها المصلحه في
التحول المدني الديمقراطي هذا الاتفاق هو
اتفاق فاشل ونحن نريد ان يتم القاء هذا
الاتفاق والنصر الى الاتفاق سياسي جديد
يقضي لمعالجه هذه الازمه السياسيه
وبالتالي ان نؤسس فتره انتخابيه جديده
وسلسه ومتعافيه من كافه الازمه السياسيه
الحاليه التي تشهد البلاد ولكن هذا يتطلب
ربما السيد الرشيد المعتصم انهاء ما كان
رائجا عن خلاف بين البرهان وحماتي هل ما
حصل بالامس يعتبر انه حاسم هذا الخلاف
في الغالب ان الصراع بين اي مواجهه مسلحه
بين الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه يعني
ليست قريبه يعني ليس بعيده يعني ليست سهله
باعتبار انه قوات الدعم السريع تاريخيا هي
قامت منذ نواتها الاولى فهي قوات داعمه
للقوات المسلحه عقيدتها لم تخرج عن عقيده
القوات المسلحه
فهذه القوات لن تواجه لن ترفع البندقيه في
وجه القوات المسلحه يعني هذا هو الراجح
يعني
ومن
والاجزاء الذين يفهمون في قضيه الامن
القومي من الابجديات هي وحده المنظومه
المنظومه العسكريه مهمه جدا يعني وحده
المنظومه العسكريه ادخال هذه القوات كلها
تحتها تحت
يعني القوات المسلحه هذا امر مهم ومن
دواعي استقرار السودان ووحدته وامنه وسلام
المجتمع
ايجار
مستقله انما بدا وكانه شيء من التخبط هو
الخلاف بشان الاتفاق الايطالي بين هذين
الرجلين تحديدا قد حسم
هناك طموحات سياسيه لا تخفى يعني تصريحات
الفريق النائب رئيس مجلس السياده السيد
حميتي يعني واضح انه لديه طموحات سياسيه
ولكن اللغه الغير احترافيه ضاره جدا وخطره
خطر على البلد وخطر عليه وخطر على العالم
مستقبل السوداني باعتبار
اللغات العسكريين والمؤسسات العسكريه
حواراتها داخليه لا تدير حواراتها في
الفضاء الاعلامي الخارجي
والحوار ليس ممنوعا على كافه المستويات
ولكن القوى الحزبيه يمكن ان تتحدث في
الفضاء الاعلامي عن صراعاتها ومشاكلها
والاعلام يشاركها هذه الحوارات
ولكن القوى العسكريه يجب ان تكون حواراتها
داخليه
والتراتبيه في القوات المسلحه ضروريه
ومهمه جدا واي تجاوز لهذا الامر يعاد خرق
ويعد خ الامن الوطني خطر على سلامه
المجتمع ومستقبل العمليه السياسيه على
العموم اعود الى عروه الصادق فيما يتعلق
بموقف الكتله
الديمقراطيه التي تطالب الجيش بالوقوف
مسافه واحده من جميع القوى السياسيه
والسؤال لماذا هذه الاستماته او ما يبدو
انها استماته في رفض مطالب هذه الكتله
فيما يخص الاتفاق الايطالي
الكتله الديمقراطيه يا عزيزتي ليست كتله
واحده وانما هي اهواء وامزجه باعتبار ان
فيهم جزء الان يقول بما قال به نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده بانما حدث في 25 انقلاب ويجب
تصحيحه وهنالك مستميتون هؤلاء التحللوا
بالمناصب والمكاسب يريدون الذود اما
اغتنموه في انقلاب 25 اكتوبر ويعتبرون ان
اي تخلي عنه جريمه في حق في حقهم ونقول ان
هؤلاء متباينون حتى في المرجعيه الدستوريه
للعمليه السياسيه هذه العمليه السياسيه
التي تجري الان تاسيسها الدستوري مبني على
دستور المحامين وهؤلاء فيه من ينادي
بدستور 2005 وفيهم من ينادي بالرجوع الى
الوثيقه الدستوريه التي مزقها وخرقها
الجنرال البرهان هذه نقاط الخلاف بيننا
وبين بعض من في الكتله الديمقراطيه اما
التواصل ما بين بعض قياداتها في القوى
الكفاح المسلح كالسيد جبريل والسيد مناوي
لم ينقطع الى الان وه امل ان يلتحقوا به
الاتفاق الاطاري اما ما نسمعه الان بان
هناك هذا الاتفاق يجب ان يلغى هذا الاتفاق
لا يستطيع احد الغاءه باعتبار ان الاسناد
الجماهيري والطيف السياسي حتى التبخيس بان
هذه كتله صغيره ولا قيمه لها بوصفنا في
المركز هؤلاء يعلمون انهم تخلقوا ما بعد
انقلاب 25 اكتوبر واسسوا كياناتهم بعد
ثوره ديسمبر المجيده لذلك لا يمكن ولا حتى
نحن نبخص مساعيهم ولا نبخف احجامهم
باعتبار ان الشعب السوداني عليم بمن يدير
الازمه السياسيه في البلاد وعليم بمن يمسك
بتل ابيب الامور هذه ليست مزايده ولا مجال
للمزايدات باننا نريد ان نضيق عليهم او
نقصيهم لا الازمه السياسيه مبدئيا مؤسسه
على خلافات مبدئيه ومنهجيه ان ارادوا
الالتحاق بالاطار عليهم ان يدينوا هذا
الانقلاب وهذه الجريمه ترتب عليها من
جرائم وصل حدها الى الشهيد ابراهيم مجذوب
123 قتيل وشهيد واكثر من الف في اقاليم
السودان المختلفه هذه جرائم الانقلاب يجب
ان يقروا بها هنالك تبديد لما يزيد عن
التمانيه مليار دولار من اموال البلاد يجب
ان يقروا بها كل هذا ان لم يقر به ويعترف
به بانه جريمه في حق الشعب السوداني لا
يمكن ان يستصحبوا في هذه العمليه هذه
العمليه اجندتها معلومه موضوعه ذهبوا الى
القاهره في يومين اتوا باجندا مطبوعه
ومكتوبه نحن الان امسك استكملنا ملف
العداله والعداله الانتقاليه في كل ربع
السودان بمشاركه اهل المصلحه الحقيقيه
وننحو مع اخوتنا العسكريين للتوجه نحو
مؤتمر السلاح القضايا العسكريه هذه
عمليه باجنده معلومه وبروافع اقليميه
ودوليه كيف لنا ان نبخسها ان ارادوا
الالتحاق بها فعليهم ان يفعلوا ما قلت
والا فسيكون هذا العواء والع ويل مصيره
ادراج الرياح ومطالب يعني
فيما يمكن وصفها بانها يمكن ان تكون
واقعيه ما الذي يحول دون تحقيقها سيد محي
الدين ابراهيم
والامر طبعا كما تعلمين يعني حديث عروه
طبعا هو حديث يعني حديث النخبه السياسيه
التي ظلت تحكم السودان بالفشل وبالتالي
نحن يجب ان لا نكرر هذه التجربه التجربه
التي اعاني منها الشعب السوداني كثيرا نحن
الان نريد ان نؤسس لفتره انتخابيه جديده
فتره يعني ان يشارك كافه القوى السياسيه
التي شاركت في اسقاط النظام وان يكون
هنالك يعني تمثيل عادي لكافه الشعب
السوداني تعلمين ايضا ان الدوله السودانيه
دوله متعدده الثقافات والاستيات والاديان
وبالتالي يجب ان نتعامل يعني مع هذا الامر
بواقعيه الشيء الثاني نحن موقفنا ايضا نحن
سنستمر في دعوتنا الى التوافق الوطني
الشامل الذي يفضي لمعالجه هذه الازمه
السياسيه وبالتالي ايضا نحن طرحنا يعني
اللجنه وطنيه
لتقريب وجهات النظر ما بين قائد قوات
الدعم السريع
وقياده المؤسسه العسكريه للوصول الى اتفاق
يعني
السياسي جديد وبالتالي ايضا ان نخرج من
هذا الاتفاق الاطار الذي يعني سبب في في
صناعه هذه الازمه الوطنيه الحاليه التي
تشهدها
قبل قليل يعني هذا الاتجاه قضيه الاصرار
على التعامل والتوقيع ككتله
لماذا لا يمكن التعامل معها ككيانات
مختلفه كما ذكر وذهب
الفاضله هذه المجموعه هي وقعت على هذا
الاتفاق الاطار ككتله سياسي وبالتالي هم
يريدون ان يضعوا معايير محدده للتعامل
معنا نحن كتله سياسيه كبيره جدا محترمه
لدينا قواعد شعبيه وجمال جماهير عريضه جدا
في كافه انهاء البلاد وبالتالي نحن لا هذه
القوه هي ليست قوه سهله وبالتالي نحن
لدينا ايضا اعلان سياسي واعلان دستوري
وخرجنا باعلان اكبر يعني الان نحن لا
ننتمي فقط الى الكتله الديمقراطيه هنالك
التنسيقيه الوطنيه هذه التنسيقيه الوطنيه
التي شاركت في ورشه القاهره الان نحن قوه
اكبر من من من السابق نحن الان طرحنا هذا
المشروع السياسي العريض الذي يفضي الى
التوافق الوطني نحن ايضا موقفنا من هذه
المجموعه التي استنسقت يعني الى مجموعات
قليله جدا والتي هي بدات يعني اربع
تنظيمات فقط سياسيه وهي معروفه للشعب
السوداني ومجربه هذه المجموعه فشلت تماما
في اداره هذه الفتره الانتخابيه وبالتالي
سريع واختلافات فيما يتعلق بهذه الكتله
اريد ان اذهب الى الرشيد المعتصم والسؤال
الذي يطرح نفسه الان ما هي الخطوه القادمه
انا في ظني ان وحده المنظومه العسكريه هي
من الاولويات والجيش في خطابه الاول
وخطاباته السابقه ظل يردد وواضح ان قبول
المؤسسه العسكريه الجيش السوداني بهذا
الاتفاق الاطاري يعني من اهم البنود التي
دفعته للموافقه على هذا الاتفاق هي وحده
المنظومه العسكريه
ولكن ظل الجيش يردد ان هذا الاتفاق يجب ان
يفتح باعتبار ان النظم الليبراليه
الديمقراطيه الحديثه تقوم على على
المشتركات وعلى الاتفاق واي اي اي اتفاق
اي اي يعني نظام سياسي لا يقوم على
الاتفاق مصيره هو الى الفشل واذا استصحبنا
ايضا يعني ضعف هذه المؤسسات الحزبيه هذه
الاحزاب ضعيفه جدا يعني هذه الاحزاب هشه
لدرجه انها شفي غايبه في يعني هذه الاحزاب
موجوده في الفضاء السياسي ليس ليس
ان نقفل هنا ان المكون العسكري وقع ايضا
على هذا الاتفاق وهو موجود لا يمكن اقفال
هذه النقطه
بس هو في الامر الغريب ان القوه الحريه
والتغيير التي يعني
ذهبت بعيدا في صراعه مع الجيش في الاتفاق
السابق الذي سمي بالوثيقه الدستوريه والذي
انتهى الى فضه الشراكه هي لا تريد ان تتفق
الا مع الجيش
والان ايضا تسعى الى الاتفاق مع الحركات
المسلحه داخل الكتله الديمقراطيه
يعني واضح ان هناك تباين للقراءات لهذا
الاتفاق ولاهميته اعود اليك كمجلس مركزي
كيف ترون اتجاه الاوضاع
تجاه الاوضاع باختصار اقول لك رغم هذا
الضجيج ستسير العمليه السياسيه الى
نهايتها بمن حضر باعتبار اننا لا نريد
اغلاق العمليه السياسيه من اصحاب المصلحه
ممن قيل انه شركاء في الثوره وهذا الباب
مفتوح وحدد الاطرافه الى ان يصلوا الينا
ولا نريد اغراقها
بالسدنه والفلول والنظام البائد وواجهته
المنصه الاخرى التي تتحدث يتحدث عنها ضيفك
الكريم مليئه بالفلوول والسدره وواجهات
الحزب المحلول يريدون ادراجها ضمن هذا
الاتفاق الايطالي وهذا ما لن نقبل به
اطلاقا لانهم سقطوا ضمن ثوره شعبيه رفضت
وجودهم فيها كذلك ستسير هذه العمليه
باعتبار انها مؤسسه على منهج وخارطه وورق
معد اي مرجعيه معده وليست باهواء وامزجه
شارك فيها وفي مؤتمراتها الاربعه التي
انقضت كما بينت ونتجه صوبا المؤتمر الاخير
لاصلاح الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه
الذي يدفعكم لرفض توسيع المشاركه اذا كان
يمكن ان يؤدي الى حل
انا لم اقل لم نقل بالرفض قلنا نحن لا
للاغلاق ولا للاغراق هنالك من يريد
اغراقها اما من تخلى عن الانقلاب وادانوا
وقال بانه خطا وانحاز الى اجندتنا
المطروحه الان في قضايا الاتفاق الاطاري
وايقن ان هذه الممارسه التي مارسوها طيله
25 بددت مكاسب البلاد السياسيه والامنيه
والاجتماعيه وليس الاتفاق الايطالي هو من
فعل ذلك وبقول العسكريين ذات انفسهم من
نادوهم الى منصه القصر الجمهوري قالوا هذا
خطا عليه من يقول بذلك
وينحازوا الى اراده الشعب التي تدعم هذا
الاتفاق ونحن لسنا حبيسي ادراج او اسافير
ذهبنا الى ولايه السودان المختلفه والان
في هذه اللحظه التي اتحدث معك فيها طواقم
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي وقول
الاطري تجوب انحاء السودان المختلفه
لاكمال المؤتمر الرابع مؤتمرات العداله
الانتقاليه الحديث عن ضعف القوى السياسيه
حديث مرد من قال به لان هذه القوه
السياسيه مع اراده الشعب الغلاب هي من
نظمت احتجاجات ابريل يناير 2018 وديسمبر
2018 ودخلت القياده العامه في
2019 وطاحت بالمخلوع هذه القوه حيه موجوده
نعم اضعفت ومرضت ولكنها لن تموت
السيد محي الدين ابراهيم المكون العسكري
في النهايه والمجلس المركزي اتفق على
المضي قدما الى اين تتجه الامور من وجهه
نظرك وما هي الخيارات امامكم
هذه المؤسسه العسكريه تعلم جيدا ان هذا
الاتفاق الاطاري لن يعالج هذه الازمه
السياسيه ونحن يعني نؤيد هذه الخطوه
بالتالي يعني اي اتفاق يعني جديد هو هو
المخرج الاساسي من هذه الازمه السياسيه
الحاليه نحن سنمضي في هذا الاتجاه لتوثيق
قائده المشاركه تشمل كافه القوه السياسيه
التي شاركت في اسقاط النظام وندعو كافه
القوى السياسيه حتى يعني التي خرجت من
الاتفاق الاطاري ان تنضم الى هذه هذه
المشاركه وايضا سوف ندعو الى يعني
مشاركه القوى القوى القوات الشابه المسلحه
بالاضافه للقوات الدام السريع ان تشارك
وان تقف على مسافه واحده من القوه المدنيه
هذه هذه هذا المطلب هو المطلب الاساسي
والذي يعني دعا اليه يعني قائد قوات الشعب
المصلى السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان في العمل
الماضي ونحن نلتزم في هذا الاتجاه وايضا
القوات المسلحه ان تلتزم ايضا بهذا المطلب
لانه هذا هو الاساسي لانه هذه القوات هي
قوات سودانيه وطنيه ويجب ان تقف على مسافه
واحده من كافه القوى السياسيه وان يعني
تدعم هذا الاتجاه وتدعم ايضا وتساهم في
عمليه التحول المدني الديمقراطي هو المخرج
الاساسي لنا جميعنا من هذه الازمه
السياسيه اشكرك احد شكرا بهذه الازمه
السياسيه شكرا جزيلا محي الدين ابراهيم
القياده في الكتله الديمقراطيه واشكرك
عروه الصادق القيادي في تحالف الحريه
والتغيير مجموعه المجلس المركزي وشكرا
للرشيد المعتصم الباحث في مركز الخرطوم
للحوار
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخمر في
[موسيقى]